auch die Ukraine ein Krieg der eine
Zeitenwende bedeutet
die Ukraine befindet sich seit einem
Jahr in einem ermutigen entschlossenen
Abwehrkampf gegen den brutalen
russischen Angriffskrieg
ich möchte hier und heute die
Gelegenheit nutzen den Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern zu danken für ihre Hingabe
ihre
Opferbereitschaft ihren Mut und ihren
unbeugsamen durchhalte Willen
Deutschland Europa alle in der Welt die
für internationale Regeln einstehen sind
der Ukraine sehr dankbar
das ist heute noch einmal ganz deutlich
geworden als wir auf Einladung von
Japans Premierminister Fumio kishida im
Kreise der G7 Staats- und
Regierungschefs zu einer Videokonferenz
zusammengefunden haben
dem ukrainischen Staatspräsidenten wurde
mir silenski haben wir abermals
versichert dass wir die Ukraine
unterstützen werden solange das nötig
ist politisch humanitär finanziell und
auch mit Waffenlieferung
39 Milliarden US-Dollar 37 Milliarden
Euro an direkter Finanzhilfe haben die
G7 Mitglieder zur Unterstützung der
Ukraine auf den Weg gebracht
Deutschland nimmt hier eine führende
Rolle ein seit Kriegsbeginn belaufen
sich die bilateralen
Unterstützungsleistungen der
Bundesregierung an die Ukraine auf über
14 Milliarden Euro
diese finanzielle Unterstützung ist über
lebenswichtig für die Ukraine denn der
Staat muss auch im Krieg in der Lage
bleiben seine Soldaten Soldaten zu
bezahlen und die staatlichen Leistungen
zu gewährleisten
wir sind uns im g7-kreis einig dass der
Internationale Währungsfonds ein
Unterstützungsprogramm für die Ukraine
auf den Weg bringen sollte und obwohl
der Krieg unvermindert tobt denken wir
schon jetzt an den Wiederaufbau dieses
schwer zerstörten Landes
im Herbst hatte ich gemeinsam mit der
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen nach Berlin eingeladen zu einer
internationalen Konferenz der
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine wird eine
Generationenaufgabe
unser Ziel ist es kluge Verfahren zu
entwickeln und meine dauerhafte
Unterstützung des Wiederaufbaus durch
internationale Finanzinstitutionen und
privates Kapital zu schaffen
neben finanzieller Unterstützung
benötigt durch unsere in der angesichts
der brutalen russischen Aggression
weiterhin Waffen um sich und ihre
Bürgern und Bürger zu verteidigen auch
das organisieren wir eine enge
Abstimmung mit unseren Partnern ist
wichtig um eine solide und
längerfristige militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine
sicherzustellen Deutschland Schuld hat
einen großen Anteil an der militärischen
Unterstützung an den Waffenlieferungen
wir haben schweres Gerät geliefert etwa
Gepard flugabwehrpanzer Panzerhaubitzen
oder mehrfach Raketenwerfer ein
Schwerpunkt unserer Militärhilfe liegt
bei dem Luftverteidigungssystem etwa der
ihres Tee
und wir haben zudem entschieden 40
Schützenpanzer Marder und 14 moderne
Kampfpanzer vom Typ Leopard 2 A6 in
diesem Frühjahr zu übergeben und werden
das auch noch weiter fokussieren
Deutschland wird gemeinsam mit Dänemark
und den Niederlanden der ukraine-leepord
1 ab 5 Kampfpanzer aus
industriebeständen liefern und wir
unterstützen die Ausbildung ukrainischer
Soldaten Soldaten an diesen Geräten
dieser Krieg ist putinskrieg Russland
hat es in der Hand diesen Krieg der
bereits zehntausende Tote gekostet und
unendliches Leid gebracht hat sofort zu
beenden in dem es die Kämpfe einstellt
und Truppen zurückzieht
die Ukraine Ukrainer zahlen den höchsten
Preis für Russlands Unrecht und
Brutalität doch die ganze Welt leidet
unter der russischen Aggression die
Preise für Energie für Dünger für
Nahrungsmittel sind massiv gestiegen
weltweit es sind die ärmsten der Welt
die am stärksten leiden
das zeigt uns es geht bei diesem Krieg
um grundsätzliche Fragen wir dürfen
nicht zulassen dass militärisches
grubellosigkeit gewinnt das Grenzen
souveräner standen gewaltsam verschoben
werden und dass sich das Recht des
Stärkeren durchsetzt
leider sehe ich auch noch einem Jahr
Krieg und Blutvergießen keinerlei
bemühen Russlands diesen
verbrecherischen Krieg zu beenden im
Gegenteil
putinen setzt weiter auf
unverantwortliches nukleares Gebaren und
stellt jetzt auch noch den letzten
Abrüstungsvertrag zu strategischen
Kernwaffen den News startvertrag mit den
USA in Frage das ist bedrückend aber wir
dürfen uns davon nicht entmutigen lassen
wir müssen den Druck aufrecht erhalten
damit Russland auf dem Boden des
Völkerrechts zurückkehrt und sich
endlich an den Verhandlungstisch setzt
dazu gehört selbstverständlich auch
wirtschaftlicher Druck wir sind uns
einig in der G7 dass wir unsere
Sanktionen weiterhin eng koordinieren
und dabei Schlupflöcher schließen wir
haben uns heute zu weiteren gemeinsamen
Maßnahmen bekannt wir wollen diese
innerhalb der EU mit dem zehnten
Sanktionspaket umsetzen und die
notwendigen Schritte ergreifen
und auch international sind wir bemüht
deutlich zu machen das Russland mit
seiner Aggression gegen die Ukraine in
der Welt alleine steht heute Abend werde
ich zum Staatsbesuch nach Indien
aufbrechen das aktuell die
Präsidentschaft der G20 innerhalb also
der 20
einflussreichsten und wirtschaftlich
stärksten Industrie und Schwellenländer
unseres Planeten
mit Premierminister Modi bin ich seit
Monaten im engen Austausch und ich werde
dort noch einmal für unseren Standpunkt
unsere Sichtweise auf diesen Konflikt
werben
heute an diesem traurigen ersten
Jahrestag des Krieges sind unsere
Gedanken bei den
Bürgern und Bürgern der Ukraine den
Menschen in Kiew in Kärcher und anderswo
die Ukraine kann sich weiter auf uns
verlassen Deutschland steht eng an ihrer
Seite wir nutzen unsere internationalen
Möglichkeiten unseren Einfluss damit die
Unterstützung der Ukraine ungebrochen
bleibt vielen Dank
eine Frage wenn Sie jetzt die letzten
zwölf Monate sich anschauen inwiefern
hat das jetzt die deutsche Politik
geprägt und wenn sie zurück gucken was
hätten sie vielleicht in den zwölf
Monaten mal anders gemacht
Russlands Angriffskrieg ist eine
Zeitenwende ich habe das gleich nach dem
Krieg so formuliert im Deutschen
Bundestag und die hat Konsequenzen zum
Beispiel dass wir mit einem Jahrzehnte
langen Tabu gebrochen haben keine Waffen
in Kriegsgebiete zu liefern wir tun das
jetzt und sind mittlerweile auf dem
europäischen Kontinent wie an vielen
Stellen auch andere jetzt festgestellt
haben vorne dabei vorne weg und machen
das in großem Umfang und werden das auch
weiterhin so handhaben wir
haben uns entschieden dass wir unsere
Landesverteidigung Stärken
dauerhaft zwei Prozent der
Wirtschaftsleistung für die Bundeswehr
ausgeben und dass wir um den Spurwechsel
zu ermöglichen ein Sondervermögen von
100 Milliarden Euro auflegen und das ist
aus meiner Sicht etwas was unser Land
verändert hat genauso wie die
in Europa
in Deutschland und übrigens sehr wie ich
gesagt habe in der ganzen Welt spürbaren
Konsequenzen dieses Krieges wir haben
viel dafür unternommen dass wir nicht
eine Wirtschaftskrise erleben dass das
soziale Miteinander weiter funktioniert
dass wir die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
unterstützen die plötzlich mit hohen
Energiepreisen und Preissteigerungen
konfrontiert sind wegen dieses Krieges
und wegen des russischen Angriffs auf
die Ukraine und selbstverständlich ist
es so dass wir auch alles dafür getan
haben dass unsere
Energieversorgungssicherheit
gewährleistet bleibt dass uns das
gelungen ist das ist glaube ich schon
etwas ganz ganz besonderes man muss ja
sich nur noch mal rekapitulieren was
alles im letzten Jahr vorhergesagt wurde
dass uns geschehen würde und deshalb ist
das für mich ein Beweis dass wir ein
wirtschaftlich starkes Land eine
gefestigte Demokratie und dann Land mit
gutem sozialen Miteinander mit einem
Sozialstaat sind und vielleicht ist das
auch etwas das wir uns noch mal neu
vergewissern sollten nach diesem ein
Jahr das ist das Fundament unserer
Möglichkeiten
Herr Bundeskanzler kurz vor dieser
Pressekonferenz ist ja auch bekannt
geworden dass Deutschland jetzt 18 statt
14 Leopard 2 Kampfpanzer schickt das ist
ja wahrscheinlich kein Zufall dass die
Entscheidung heute bekannt oder
getroffen wurde welche Botschaft soll
denn damit nach draußen gehen
wir haben uns sehr darum bemüht dass wir
die
Ukraine unterstützen und haben gesagt
wir werden einen Beitrag dazu leisten
dass die
Kampfpanzer die wir liefern zusammen mit
der Unterstützung anderer dazu beitragen
dass wir auch eine entsprechende
entsprechend große Zahl von Panzern
gemeinsam liefern können wir haben jetzt
was die moderneren
Leopard Panzer die wir liefern betrifft
Angebote aus Portugal zum Beispiel und
Schweden jetzt heute ganz neu und mit
der weiteren Fokussierung so habe ich
das eben wir haben die Zahl genannt
unserer Maßnahme mit den anderen
Angeboten ist das dann auch so dass wir
in der Lage sind das zustande zu bringen
was wir angekündigt haben an
Kooperationen in Europa und dann
Unterstützung der Ukraine mit einer
Einheit die die richtige Größenordnung
hat und wir werden ja das Weitermachen
im Hinblick auf die
Ausbildung auch
Nachschub auf Munition auf
instandhaltungsanforderungen genauso wie
das unsere Kooperation gibt bei den
Aktivitäten die viele andere Staaten
jetzt noch unternehmen und Stück für
Stück hoffen wir dass es da Fortschritte
gibt und sieht ja heute dass das gelingt
und das beharrliches bemühen sich
auszahlt
vielen Dank Herr Bundesregierung nein
eine abschließende Frage werden eben
gerade eure Reise nach Indien
angesprochen indien hat es gerade den
Vorsitz der G20 in Bali war Indien noch
eines der Länder die sich auch dafür
eingesetzt hatte die
von der klare Sprache den Angriffskrieg
Russland gegen Ukraine klar zu benennen
nun hat Indien 20 Vorsitz gezeichnet
dass Indien weniger entschlossen ist
diesen Krieg als solchen zu bezeichnen
wie zuversichtlich sind Sie dass
Europa und USA den globalen Süden und
dessen Vertreter weiter an Ort halten
können um den Druck auf Putin zu erhöhen
und Putin zu isolieren
es war das Verdienst Indiens Indonesiens
Indonesiens als Präsidentschaft der G20
in letzten Jahr aber auch andere Länder
wie Südafrika oder Argentinien die dazu
beigetragen haben dass wir so klare
Sprache gefunden haben bei dem
G20-Gipfel letztes Jahr und insofern
geht es darum dass wir jetzt weiterhin
dafür Sorge tragen dass wir klar und
deutlich bleiben und eine der
Voraussetzungen dafür dass das gelingen
kann ist natürlich dass wir ernsthaft
das machen wofür ich jetzt schon sehr
sehr lange werbe auch unabhängig von dem
aktuellen Konflikt nämlich dass wir
mit
starken Ländern Asiens Afrikas und des
Südens Amerikas
gute Beziehungen aufbauen die auch in
den nächsten Jahrzehnten prägen tragen
die auf Augenhöhe stattfinden und mit
vielen anderen natürlich auch aber
gerade denen um die es ja geht wenn wir
jetzt auch über G20 sprechen und ich
finde das ein ganz ganz wichtigen
Fortschritt wenn das die internationalen
Beziehungen mehr prägt und wenn viele
andere mitmachen ich kann ihnen
berichten dass bei der G7 Konferenz das
praktisch von allen noch mal genannt
wurde auch angesprochen wurde dass das
ein sehr guter Schritt war dass wir bei
dem g7-gipfel in Deutschland in Ellmau
genau das gemacht haben und seither ist
dass die Politik aller bei den G7
versammelten Staaten und das ist
wirklich eine Veränderung die glaube ich
für eine bessere Zukunft steht und die
uns auch wichtig sein muss muss ich habe
in meiner Rede bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz den indischen ein
Vertreter Indiens zitiert der indischen
Regierung der gesagt hat Europa und das
gilt dann ja nicht nur für Europa
sondern auch andere Länder des
globalen Westens
muss lernen
Europas Probleme nicht immer die
Probleme der Welt sind und umgekehrt
dass die Probleme der Welt auch Europas
Probleme sind und das ist finde ich
etwas was
glaube ich ein guter Ansatz ist wenn wir
versuchen die Welt als ganze zu
betrachten und eine solche Politik zu
entfalten und aus meiner Sicht ist das
wirklich etwas was dafür spricht auch so
intensiv diese Beziehung weiter zu
fliegen wie wir das jetzt tun und damit
nicht nach zulassen
[Musik]
das war der Bundeskanzler heute eine
Pressekonferenz nach dem